hi I'm dr. Drew ratings here to tell you
how you can safely watch the solar
eclipse or CNN you've decided to spend
your entire day focused on a large
orange ball of gas so you'll need to
take the appropriate safety precautions
first you'll need some protective
eyewear as direct exposure is extremely
dangerous especially for children even
90 seconds of unfiltered viewing can
result in permanent injury and no
multiple pairs of sunglasses aren't
enough to protect you you'll know you've
been exposed for too long if you begin
to see things differently and notice
things you never did before like the
color of people's faces you're properly
situated you'll see this large orange
star become eclipsed by a smaller white
mass that's rarely seen in the daylight
you'll be presented with an alternate
reality day will seem like night and in
that darkness much focus will be given
to these creepy looking white fringe
elements this will be the best thing to
happen to them in years if you're able
to snap a picture there's a lot of money
to be made in making them seem larger
than they are and in that darkness you
may feel less safe than you did before
you might even hear a wolf but remember
if you're lucky this will happen just
once in your lifetime from all of us
here at the American ophthalmology
sociation be safe out there
[Music]